you have done I believe five Shakespeare
adaptations with the last one being in
2006 have you come close to doing
another one I'm always close to doing
another one you know I sometimes I've
spent a lot of time thinking about
animated Shakespeare but I always I
always wait for the moment when the
desire to do it becomes an absolute need
and not just I want not just a kind of a
sort of desire but an absolute
persistent need because that's that's
how you're probably going to achieve it
and so animated Shakespeare King Lear is
a project that's been you know circling
me for quite some time and so these
things I know also benefit from sort of
long-term marination I try and do that
and listen to the universe as to whether
there's a moment to try and put your
foot down on the on the accelerator if
you're in a position to do anything
about that
so yes I've been close but so far the
time hasn't arrived for another one thus
far I have to do a follow-up I believe
that we're in the middle of a
Renaissance in terms of animation I'm
constantly amazed with what's being put
on the screen can you share what you've
envisioned in what's percolating in
terms of an animated Shakespeare well
frankly I because I love the work so
much they dance around the place but an
obvious one that actually came to my
mind a lot when I was doing Artemis Fowl
was a midsummer night's dream simply
because the use of magic by Shakespeare
in that play is so such a fantastic
invitation to the human imagination and
so the world of visual effects as we now
know it can find a way to interpret a
character like puck saying I'll put a
girdle around the earth in 40 minutes in
ways that could really give you such a
cinematic thrill in all sorts of forms
animation IMAX animation who knows so I
continue to enjoy noodling and
percolating